democratic mayors not happy after
getting just a tiny taste of biden's
border crisis brand new video showing a
busload of migrants arriving in
washington d.c from texas early this
morning the influx has mayor muriel
bowser fuming she's asking for the
national guard to be activated after the
illegal immigrants started jamming up
her city's homeless shelters bowser is
calling it a humanitarian crisis and is
lashing out at red state governors
well it's obviously politically
motivated um and the reason why
we're different uh in this is that
people aren't coming to d.c
as their final destination what we see
is that they are moving on to their
final destinations through d.c
and the white house accusing republicans
of using migrants as political pawns
what republicans are doing the way that
they're meddling in the process and
using uh migrants as a political pond is
just wrong so the white house's
preference would be for small towns in
texas and arizona to have to take care
of these migrants rather than a large
metropolitan
washington post that is
i said that there is
yeah they are they're sending migrants
to big cities on purpose using them as a
political point
but texas isn't backing down governor
greg abbott vowing to continue busting
migrants to our nation's capital and
others in the gop are calling out the
d.c mayor for complaining
it's interesting hearing the mayor of
washington d.c which is where i'm
sitting right now complaining about 4
000 people on 200 buses that governor
abbott has sent to washington dc since
april running to the pentagon saying oh
my gosh we need the national guard oh
well you know what crimea freaking river
right you know welcome to the party pal
why don't they secure the border because
what has happened because of their
actions every single community in
america is now a border
city this is a national crisis listen
you play stupid games you win stupid
prizes and in this case they have
declared themselves a sanctuary city so
they're going to get every ounce of what
that means
katie
dc just like new york
sanctuary city the mayor could call ice
i guess because they're here illegally
she could it's interesting to listen to
her speak about how their final
destination is not dc as if that's okay
so as long as she's not dealing with the
problem it's fine if other people are
dealing with the problem it's
interesting that the mayor of the
nation's capital is not welcoming these
people with open arms given the
narrative of the left that everybody who
crosses the border illegally should be
welcome to stay in whatever community
that that they choose
it's not true to say that republican
governors are sending these people all
over the country the federal government
for a year and a half has been sending
and flying illegal immigrants by the
thousands to cities across the country
in the dead of night because they know
that they're doing something wrong
they've been completing transactions
essentially for cartels because they get
them to the border the smugglers and
then they pick them up and ship them off
on planes to a bunch of different
communities all around the country
looking back at the headlines from 2018
when president trump decided to send the
national guard to an international
border the mexican border the united
states
are amazing given what the mayor of dc
is asking for now they said that he was
militarizing the border he was
xenophobic he was racist that this was
not something the military should be
used for democratic governors like the
one in oregon refused to send the
national guard to be part of securing
the border through the national guard
most recently texas governor greg abbott
has been using the national guard to
build fencing along the border because
the
biden administration refuses to finish
the federal fence as cartels continue to
profit by the billions of dollars off of
human smuggling so it's ironic it's
interesting
i am very interested to see how this
tent city that they're going to set up
in washington d.c plays out with the
national guard
essentially processing these people in
the capitol
but they
are living by their own rules now and
this is what they were perfectly fine
with before right it's
startling joey to see how the
i used mayor eric adams here in new york
city how they have completely erased
things that they said like a year ago
where mayor adams was running
running for the job and saying illegal
immigrants are welcome here we're going
to offer you so many more services and
now he is complaining wall to wall about
being inundated and blaming the
callousness of border states that push
these people out and push them into new
york and the reason that some illegal
immigrants here are homeless with not
winding up in shelters is because dhs
biden's dhs is giving them the wrong
destination information and these
illegal migrants don't know where
they're going here in the city you know
4 000 people lose their jobs every time
uh you know one party takes control of
the house over the other i mean you know
to be a little bit light-hearted about
this 4 000 people that's what she's
calling humanitarian crisis like i
thought the number would be forty
thousand or or ten thousand or fifteen
thousand and chip roy was absolutely
right go to texas and see what one
municipality of ten thousand people are
dealing with i mean their own population
doubles triples quadruples that's what
they're dealing with and for some reason
with this national effort from the
democratic party to open our borders uh
d.c shouldn't have to deal with that and
i really didn't understand her point
about it being a transient place i
didn't understand how that made them
different other than it's unless she's
acknowledging that these immigrants
actually do want to go to places in the
northeast
or on the east coast i'm from a town
that in the 90s when you came up from
mexico you went through texas you took
i-40 or i-20 you came over you went to
memphis tennessee that area and the
other went down to florida or over to
north carolina people laugh at me or
they look surprised when i say that my
town in north georgia was subtitled in
spanish
the idea that illegal immigration only
affects arizona and texas or from their
words only should affect arizona and
texas really makes no sense when you
look at where illegal immigrants
actually are and no municipality is is
in preparation for four thousand forty
thousand or ten thousand people without
jobs and homes to come into their
community and that's the injustice of
the border and that's the injustice of
this administration's border policy
which is to bring people into the
country with with no means or
opportunity available to them because
they're not enfranchised into this
country they're here illegally and say
well we'll do a court date in two years
and then we'll figure it out there
harold there are 900 000 got aways
illegal immigrants who got out of
custody got got into the country in
under two fiscal years so
yeah four to joey's point four thousand
mayor muriel bowser's upset about that
where do you think these individuals are
gonna go sanctuary cities
right so i i don't disagree a lot with
what's been said but i would add a few
things uh first this problem has existed
a long time it's worse today than it's
been ever when i was in congress we were
grappling with with this issue two
democrats have to understand
that this issue whether it's right or
wrong fair or not we're going to get
blamed for a lot of this at the
presidential level uh even though it's
been a problem that's persistent i'd
have five elements as part of a deal and
i don't know how issues should do this
my orientation to politics is not the
yell and scream although that's probably
a good gig i'd like to figure out how
you get things done
democrats you gotta negotiate
republicans and build a wall
republicans you gotta negotiate with
democrats and send more judges and
reform the asylum process
both of you should be willing to send
both parties should be willing to send
people like tires down many people like
tirestown who are trained and smart down
to help law enforcement there
at the border four
we need to invest in that hemisphere in
some ways also not dumb investments not
silly things not again not well thought
out things we spend trillions to
stabilize other parts of the world we
spend pennies to stabilize our own
hemisphere and then finally the drugs
and the gangs worry me worry me even as
much if not more so than some of the
things that you guys have eloquently
said already we need a fentanyl task
force if this is coming from china and
going there and coming into our country
we've got to figure out ways in which to
stop this for me it's not democrat or
republican it's right or wrong and it's
stupid or smart and right now we're
we're the wrong s
uh in the stupid or smart uh dichotomy
as a country and perhaps i think both
parties have some blame but
unfortunately president biden and the
team
we're in charge and we have a greater
responsibility it's biden's open border
and that policy alone has laid the
foundation for people to profit from
human suffering and misery fentanyl and
human trafficking and human trouble you
bring me human trafficking also i'm
sorry
well
it's only his border when he's affected
see i always talk about the unaffected
always like to tell you what to do until
they're affected and she's affected now
and it's it's a mess
and we live in a time where we change
the meanings of words right because
recession doesn't mean recession anymore
and apparently that sanctuary cities
doesn't mean sanctuary cities anymore so
we'll play the game republicans we're
not very good at this but i'm going to
try it's not going to be build the wall
we're going to call it build the
aquarium so we're going to build a nice
aquarium and they've already started
building the aquarium in arizona they
are not finishing the wall they are
building an aquarium in the desert so
build the dam aquarium so we can
aquarium
i don't know where i come from we change
many words all the time so we do we're a
little bit let me see like let's just go
with that but i'm being funny but it's
yeah build the damn wall i don't care
what you call it take credit for it
whatever you want to do it back up our
law enforcement
treat ice right
and do your part if you're going to be a
sanctuary city be a sanctuary city
i was going to say where all of us are
from
we actually use the right words but
people outside of where we grew up they
don't know that we're using the right
word they can't understand it
trump gave pelosi this deal he gave her
daca and he gave her uh visa reform to
fund the wall and she couldn't let him
have the win and here we are today
so coming up
aquariums
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now